Gene Simmons saw me on Merv Griffin and
hired me to be Diana Ross's opening act
and you asked me the question before we
walked into this room that's
unbelievable phenomenal
cool yeah and to think that at this age
you know coming up on 70 yeah uh that
I'd still be sitting I am old that I'd
be sitting here in a warehouse with a
bunch of toys having fun with really
funny people is unbelievable and is a
dream come true yeah that's badass yeah
killer that's badass it is killer dude
there's also something so romantic about
old school comedy that you would do a
set and then someone like Gene Simmons
would see you and be like oh you should
open for Diana Ross you know when you
did TV in those days in the 70s and the
early 80s if you got on TV yeah your
life was never the same you know whereas
today you can be on TV every day I mean
it's crazy and nobody knows your name
yeah and no and they say it's a hit show
and nobody knows who you know I I I've
always used this example where it's CSI
which is I think a hit show right who
stars in CSI I mean which one you know
but I don't know the name exactly
whereas you knew in in the 80s you knew
the third person in the credits on any
show so it doesn't and then if you got
out of the comedy store or the Improv
there was two clubs here yeah you were
going to get seen by every Network or
anybody that had anything to do with
anything and today you have to break
through maybe somebody will hear you on
a podcast a lot of people were seen
don't you understand how unique it is
that you were seen it's not about me and
you blew the roof off yeah but but the
point is there's a lot of people who can
blow the roof off today and not get seen
and not have those eyes on them yeah but
I also think there's that you're telling
me yeah but I also think there's a
difference of people now can
um kind of manifest their own
opportunities by if they're really good
Savvy online if they're good with you
know putting oh absolutely you know the
the the guy I'm looking at right now is
like Matt Rife what he's doing an
unbelievable amount but amazing and it
just like he's been around for a long
time it's not from him on being on TV
from Nick Cannon show it's from his yeah
Tick Tock yeah I thought that's
brilliant yeah but you know before that
Dane Cook yeah you know after like after
my era which was doing The Tonight Show
or you know getting on any TV then Dane
Cook was the first guy to use MySpace
yes completely blow up you know one of
my best friends is Nate bargetti and
I've watched Nate
um do a ton of tonight shows did a ton
of Conan you know he was doing all these
late night shows but it was other things
that it wasn't those things that blew
him up but those helped but it was kind
of the same thing as Russell Peters
Russell Peters is another guy from
Toronto who um did these I think Lou you
did one of these two though CBC or CTV
yes half hour comedy special he did that
it was on television Donnie anyway he he
did one of those half hour comedy
specials and it you know he was a
working journeyman comic sure for some
reason somebody put it on YouTube
Russell Peters yeah and talk about
blowing up internationally he blew up
all over the world like he's so much
bigger all over the world than people
know him right here but he was playing
Arenas and before this whole Arena thing
yeah came in to be and that was from
YouTube yeah so it's changing and now I
think the way into a career if you ask
me is AI but let me ask you this
question seriously if you were coming in
the business today you were 21 years old
22 years old in the business today and
you did something on YouTube
don't you think it would have blown up
even bigger not necessarily I think you
have to be I think you have to first of
all I can't do one thing on YouTube and
hope that that's gonna make it and
that's going to do it no but I think
that what happens with people who are on
social media today it's about
consistency like it continues you
continue to put out put out put out you
put momentum and you need momentum and
you need consistency and you also need
to figure out how whatever that is how
do you package that how do you what is
your thumbnail what is your click bait
what is your what time AI that can
control that for you too so they can
tell you what it takes it full circle
what kind of content you should be
making what is the best clip from this
podcast that you should be putting up
what should the title be that will get
the most hits
[Music]